one moment that appears as the essence
that is stepped to one side is a
universal medium whereas the subsistence
of independent matters but the
independence of these matters is nothing
else than this medium or in other words
the unconditioned Universal is simply
and solely the plurality of the diverse
universals of this kind that within
itself the universal is an undivided
unity with this plurality means however
that these matters are each where the
other is they mutually interpenetrate
but without coming into contact with one
another because conversely the many
diverse matters are equally independent
this also means that they are absolutely
porous or are sublated this sublation in
its turn this reduction of the diversity
to a pure being for self is nothing
other than the medium itself and this is
the independence of the different
manners in other words the matters
posited as independent directly pass
over into their unity and their unity
directly unfolds its diversity and this
once again reduces itself to unity but
this movement is what is called force
one of its moments the dispersal of the
independent matters and their immediate
being is the expression of force but
force taken as that in which they have
disappeared is forced proper force which
has been driven back into itself from
its expression first however the force
which is driven back into itself must
express itself and secondly it is still
forced remaining within itself in the
expression just as much as it is
expression in this self contain anise
when we thus preserve the two moments in
their immediate unity the understanding
to which the notion of force belongs is
strictly speaking the notion which
sustains the different moments qua
different for in themselves they are not
supposed to be different
consequently the difference exists only
in thought that is to say what has been
posited in the foregoing is in the first
instance only the notion
for snot it's reality in point of fact
however force is the unconditioned
Universal which is equally in its own
self what it is for an other or which
contains the difference in its own self
for difference is nothing else than
being for another in order then that
force may in truth be it must be
completely set free from thought it must
be posited as a substance of these
differences that is first the substance
as this whole force remaining
essentially in and for itself and then
it's differences as possessing
substantial being or as moments existing
on their own account force as such or as
driven back into itself thus exists on
its own account as an exclusive one for
which the unfolding of the different
matters is another subsisting essence
and thus to distinct interdependent
independent aspects are set up but force
is also the whole that is it remains
what it is according to its notion that
is to say these differences remain pure
forms superficial vanishing moments at
the same time there would be no
difference at all between force proper
which has been driven back into itself
and force unfolded into independent
matters if they had no enduring being or
there would be no force if it did not
exist in these opposite ways but then it
does exist in these opposite ways simply
means that the two moments are at the
same time themselves independent it is
therefore this movement to the two
moments in which they perpetually give
themselves independence and then
supersede themselves again which we are
now to consider in general it is clear
that this movement is nothing else than
the movement of perceiving in which the
two sides the percipient and what is
perceived are indistinguishably one in
the apprehension of the truth and yet
each side is at the same time equally
reflected into itself or has a being of
its own here these two sides are moments
of force they are just as much in a
unity as this unity which appears as the
middle term over against the independent
extremes is a perpetual direction of
itself into just these extreme
which exists only through this process
thus the movement which previously
displayed itself as the self destruction
of the contradictory notions here as
it's a has objective form and is the
movement of force the outcome of which
is the unconditioned universal as
something not objective or as the inner
being of things
in Section 136 we have another one of
these very long lots of things going on
lots of balls being thrown in the air
and juggled look perhaps of leaving a
little bit of sleight of hand going on
if we're not careful sections and I
think we're going to devoting an entire
video just to that because this is a
really important one to pay close
attention to it I want to suggest that
other sections aren't equally important
but there's there's a lot going on here
Hale is bringing some things to a close
in the very early part he's introducing
a new really important term force or
crops the the title of this section is
force and the understanding so we know
that this is going to be a turning point
and that is giving us ready for what's
going to be happening next he's
introducing some some very important
distinctions some movements that are
taking place and we want to focus in on
exactly what's happening here in part
because it's going to be a rocky road
ahead so one other thing to remind
ourselves of before we launch into this
is what have we done in the last four
paragraphs that began this section we
looked at the the dialectic going on in
in the thing in the sensible object the
the the object of perception and we saw
that there are all these different ways
of looking at it and you know the
understanding plausibly is what binds
them together but they did they lack of
internal unity what we were looking for
there is what Hegel calls the
unconditioned Universal the unbanked
allgemeine alga by night and and we're
going to be looking for that through the
rest of this section and force is going
to offer us one of the possible ways to
understand this it's not gonna want for
us the entire way but that's going to
play a central role within it so as
we're going through this you want to
keep that goal in mind that we're not
just trying to latch on to things for
their own
we're trying to make sense out of the
totality we're trying to get to the
bottom of things or as he's gonna say a
little bit later on to the inner of
things so let's begin where this this
passage begins Hegel says that you know
what we've got here within the the thing
within the substance within whatever
word is that were paying attention to
you says we've got an essence that has
stepped to the side as a universal
medium or it has the subsistence of
individual matters and we've seen this
play out before we have a connection
between unity and plurality there's a
back and forth between these each of
these can be understood as a sensuous
you know universal this also can be
understood he has in a certain sense of
universal to unity lying beyond it the
one of those opposed to the also can be
understood as a universal but now we're
going to try to get beyond that
he says the independence of these
matters is nothing else than this medium
or the unconditioned Universal the
universal is simply and solely the
plurality of the diverse universals of
this kind so at this point the
unconditioned universal it is the
interplay between these the fact that
this provides them with the medium which
gives them you might say a centrality of
focus on the other hand these are what
exist in the medium they stand out on
their own they're independent of each
other he's you know we've seen this
movement before he says within itself
the universal is in undivided unity with
this plurality and what that means is
the manners are each way or the other is
they mutually interpenetrate without
coming into contact with one another
because conversely the many matters are
independent again this looks like the
starting point that we were reaching at
the end of sense perception where we
realize that we're dealing with
universals
and an object for perception and
at the end of perception itself where we
realized that when you were trying to
bring all of these different aspects
these different metaphysical staff you
know stat statuses or or conditions
together and how are we going to get
past this
well the key lies in the fact that we're
talking about here as a movement so he
says this means that they're absolutely
porous these matters or they are
sublated there have been raised to a
higher level a higher level for the
understanding which has been carrying
out that operation or consciousness so
where do we go from here
he says that's ablation the reduction of
diversity to pure being for self is
nothing other than media so the medium
itself is where the being for self of
these independent matters each one
considered on its own run out of zis add
something else in there each one of
these has its being for self but it has
its being for self you remember we saw
this already being for self already
implies being for another they are for
another this way they are also for
another this way they are being for self
in this universal medium which means
that they all kind of have it together
don't they and at the same time they
shouldn't be doing that because they are
independent of each other so we reach a
kind of impasse at least for static
thinking he goes on he says this is the
Independence of the divert of the
different manners in other words the
matters posited as independent by
presenting them as independent we lead
them back to a unity in the universal
medium so independence brings about
dependence there's a a dialectical shift
that's occurring here something cannot
be totally radically independent without
that imply
some sort of dependency or some sort of
inclusion in something else
independence you might say is not truly
independent of all sorts of other things
we want to you know do something
platonic play with that so he goes ahead
and he says the unity itself directly
unfolds its diversity you notice I've
got arrows going both ways here so we've
got this kind of ebb and flow happening
the matters when we consider them they
lead us back to a unity when we look at
that unity what is the unity of these
independent matters there's a back and
forth constantly going on a movement
here's what we're gonna get to force so
he says this movement itself is what we
call force so if this movement is what
force is you might say well that sounds
kind of strange when I think of force
I'm not thinking of some metaphysical
schema or you know some schema of
understanding or perception along these
lines what I'm thinking of is you know
the force of gravity I drop this truck
and it falls or the force of you know
things pushing against each other or you
know force and in societal ways you know
the pressure of social conformity or the
force of an idea or the power that a
speaker brings I'm not necessarily
thinking in these terms but Hegel says
well look I'm not trying to give you a
definition right off of that I'm
characterizing what's going on here and
this this this phenomenon as it unfolds
reveals to us the nature of force which
now we want to explore what can we say
about force force has as we're going to
see two main moments to it in this
section at least and it's going to be an
interplay between these two moments on
the one hand we have the expression of
force he says the matter is positive is
independent directly peso community
this unfolds their their diversity that
reduces to unity this is what is called
force the dispersal of the independent
manners in their immediate being is the
expression of force so we've got this
morality over here becoming what it is
that the force is actually expressing
what it is what is you know putting
under one heading it's what we see
it's the phenomena that's what we take
it then he says force taken is that in
which they've disappeared
we get back to something else is force
proper force per se force as force is or
at least as we think that it is at this
point in time so he calls this force
driven back from its expression
he says the the force which is driven
back into itself in turn must express
itself so again we have this dialectical
back-and-forth movement here you don't
get one side without the other force is
neither solely the force proper driven
back into itself nor solely the
expression of force because you need
both sides in order to make sense out of
what a force actually is he goes on he
says if force remaining within itself in
the expression right so as it's
expressing itself it's carrying this
forward the force that is driven back
into itself is coming out in the
expression of force that's the only
place where it can in fact come out and
we're going to see that this has a lot
of important implications now we gotta
do a little bit of erasure what we now
hit up here is a diagram which is going
to help us understand the second part of
this long paragraph we're not going to
be able to play out everything and I
think necessarily going on in the rest
of this paragraph just by using this
diagram but it's gonna be very helpful
for quite a few of the passages
now higgles going to bring in this other
term that we've had before but we want
to concentrate on because this is it
after all force and the understanding
Hegel's going to say that the notion of
force is something that only the
understanding or consciousness as we're
gonna see is able to grasp that the
force itself is not yet its notion or
another way of putting this the notion
has not yet entirely become the notion
as we saw in some of the previous
paragraphs so he says when we preserve
the two moments what are the two moments
force and expression and force proper
driven back into itself we preserve
these two moments in their immediate
unity the understanding is strictly
speaking the notion which sustains at
different moments is different so when
we're looking at different kinds of
forces you could say that what's going
on here is the understanding is in fact
being productive and here it's worth
talking a little bit about Conte and
also about Hume we could bring up other
thinkers as well like live Nets or
Berkeley or John Locke but let's just
stick with with hunt one of the cons
basic insights that he was producing and
part to try to respond to Hume human
argued that look when it comes down to
it the regularities that we observe you
know and call cause and effect upon
which a lot of our reasoning is based
aren't really there you know we have no
reason to to you know extrapolate from
however many experiences we have of what
it is that we we perceive what we see
being expressed to there being some sort
of something behind the scenes that's
not there in any one of the given
experiences and cont is going to say you
know Humes right in a sense you can't
actually
be visually or orally or in some other
sense way see or hear or whatever caused
an effect but what you can do is do more
than just infer it we actually project
this as a way of making sense out of the
entire universe so is it there in the
universe well it is there in a sense
because we put it there because that's
one of the conditions of the possibility
of having coherent experience now of
course this is very you know bullet
point cuts I don't want people to get
upset and say oh well you know he didn't
say exactly that because we're not
worried so much about what Contin saying
but but what Hagel is doing with this
idea Hegel thinks that the understanding
is both grasping the unity force as
force in itself and force in its
expression because there is a unity
there that that is a metaphysical unity
but it's also noting the difference
between these and the understanding is
doing something I don't want to say
unique but the understanding is doing
something new by by contributing that he
says the difference exists only in
thought the difference between these two
so that he says that it's the same what
has been posited in the foregoing is in
the first instance only the notion of
force not it's reality so here we have a
bifurcation between reality or what it
is or what is supposed to be and what
our minds are able to grasp of it this
is something that you see modern
philosophy almost obsessively worried
about and we've plumbed this in the last
section about perception remember
perception was not only about perception
but the possibility of deception and
whose responsibility is that and we saw
consciousness trying to take
responsibility for it and then
discovering that the responsibility
didn't line just within consciousness
and in songs you know stupid mistakes or
things like that or biases but within
the nature of
reality itself that reality is dynamic
reality produces contradictions reality
you know produces these these splittings
in two different aspects that then we
have to try to bind back together same
thing is going to happen here with the
force so he goes on and he says in point
of fact force is the unconditioned
Universal which is equally in its own
self what it is for another or which
contains the difference in its own self
and here he says look when we have
difference what is difference difference
means being for another this is
something that we we've hit on before
but I'd like to dwell on this a little
bit when we talk about two things being
different from another that means that
we are having them placed into relation
with each other and they're being now in
in some way effects or matters for the
other they are in relation to the other
the chalk is in relation to my hand it
has being for another in relation to my
hand
it also has being for another in
relation to your eyeballs as you're
looking at this through the camera lens
it can be quite mediated if we want to
but that's the basic point that
difference involves being for another
now can it just be being for another
that has to be incorporated here he says
you know whatever that truth may be it
must be completely set free from
thoughts so there's a sijin taking place
here between the understanding or
thought consciousness and the
unconditioned universal it looks like
we're actually losing hold over the
dialectical process or at least we're
gonna have to play some catch-up in a
bit so he goes on and he says must be
completely so free from thought it must
be positive as the substance the
substance of these differences first and
the substance as this whole force
remaining essentially in and for itself
right being something that exists in its
own right whether we care about it
whether we're gonna gauged with it or
not forces there before we come onto the
scene and start doing all of our
dialectical tricks and you know talking
about consciousness force is ongoing we
enter into the scene and we start you
know thinking about it but it has being
in and for itself apart from loss apart
from whatever we're contributing to it
so he goes anime says it's substance
right first force essentially in for
itself so force per se and then in its
differences as possessing substantial
being so each one of these each one
these extremes also possesses
substantial be it didn't leave quite
enough room there right each of them is
so the force has driven back into itself
the force per se is it has substantial
being the force in its expression have
substantial being it is two they are
both there and they are both a unity
together so he says forces such driven
back into itself thus exists on its own
account as an exclusive one for which
the unfolding of the different matters
is another subsisting essence unless two
independent aspects are set up so this
is very important this development here
force driven back into itself force in
expression are two substantive aspects
that are existing or are being in
relation to each other we're going to
see this play itself out quite a bit in
the following sections so he says force
is also the whole it remains what it is
according to its notion that is these
differences remain pure form some
superficial vanishing moments at the
same time there would be no difference
at all between force proper which has
been driven back into itself and force
them folded into independent matters of
the
during being so they're undergoing this
oscillation insofar as we're looking at
them in terms of force per se each of
these is a vanishing moment we're going
to see this vanishing play itself out in
the subsequent paragraphs but you can't
have vanishing moments you can't build
nothing out of nothing there has to be
some substantiality there in order for
there to be an interplay between these
in order for force as a whole to be
something it's parts or it's moments
must be something as well they have to
have a kind of unity so we're going to
see this back you know back and forth
between total independence total reality
what we call the unconditioned Universal
and being part of a larger totality
which itself is the unconditioned
Universal so he says that it does exist
in these opposite way as simply wound
means that the two moments are at the
same time themselves independent it is
therefore this movement of the two
moments in which they perpetually give
themselves independence that's a really
key point right there these these two
moments aren't giving themselves and
giving each other
independence then they supersede
themselves again which we are now to
consider so he's going to go on and say
it's clear that this movement is nothing
else than the movement of perceiving in
which the two sides of percipient and
what is perceived are indistinguishably
one in the apprehension of the true I'm
not actually gonna erase anything here
because we we're not gonna try to locate
anything here what are we talking about
what is going on in perception what has
been leading us to try to get to this
unconditioned Universal is our drive for
the truth for truth truth you might say
with a capital T I know it's you know
capitalized and in this then it's
capitalized of course in German just
because of the conventions of grammar
but it should be capitalized in this
sense because we're not just talking
about truth as correspondence between
things or truth is existing in our
intellect we're driving after what
most real most substantive what we can
put ourselves in touch with and you know
find true to find use true here find a
surplus of meaning find something
inexhaustible within that is what he's
talking about and he's saying that in
perception itself the perceiver and the
perceived are in such a relation that
truth is happening there and it's not
just truth as correspondence between
what the perceiver perceives and the
object over here there's something large
or uniting them that's going to be like
this so he says each side is at the same
time equally reflected into itself has a
being of its own and yet the the
precipitant and the perceived are
indistinguishably one in the
apprehension of the truth so truth is
not something that just exists in the
perceiver it is something that binds the
perceiver and the perceived up together
it is a larger relation between the two
it is something that total eise's them
so he says here the two sides are
moments of force that's why he's
bringing that up you wanted to talk
about what we've been through before and
now connect that to this one of these
two moments of force they are just as
much a unity as this unity which appears
as the middle term the substance is now
a middle term between force and
expression and force proper or force as
it is force driven back into itself
it's a perpetually says Direction a
unfolding and emptying of itself into
these two things splitting into these
extremes which exists only through this
process thus the movement which
previously displayed itself as the
self-destruction of contradictory
notions he says here has objective form
and it is the movement of force the
outcome of which is the unconditioned
Universal but not as something objective
he's not as something gig and standing
like having a you know the shape of an
object and something that stands opposed
to us although it does stand opposed to
us doesn't it in the understand
because you know Hegel's been saying
that this passage that look the
understanding the thought is not the
same thing as the force we're gonna see
that that's going to get undone a little
bit later says this is going to give us
the inner being of things so what we've
been seeking this entire time the truth
that we thought was within beings or
within our perception of beings turns
out to be the totality of our relation
to them and we're understanding it and
now we're bringing in a yet another term
this idea of force which we think is
going to bring things together even more
and reveal to us the inner being of
things the inner being of the phenomena
that were paying attention to that were
captivated by that we desire that we act
upon and we're going to look first at
force and expression because that's
where we're we're seeing the engagement
with things